[Music]
well if you've been listening to this
show for any length of time you've
almost certainly heard me mention the
libs of tick tock account on twitter i
mention it because that's where i get
like 75 of my show prep but also because
the person running the account is easily
among the top three journalists in
america now granted almost all
journalists these days are morally
bankrupt propagandas so it's not a very
stiff competition but still the woman
behind the libs of tick tock account
performs a valuable
journalistic service
her primary focus as the twitter handle
suggests is tick tock she finds insane
leftist drivel on that platform and
calls attention to it and this is
important and i imagine rather
emotionally exhausting
work not just because the videos she
finds are often morbidly hilarious
though they are but because tick tock is
by far the most popular social media app
among the younger generations and by
revealing the sorts of things that are
posted on tick tock she's pointing the
spotlight into the disturbing and often
rather baffling environment where
millions of kids are being molded and
formed
i mean social media isn't just an app on
a phone it's where people especially
kids
live
it takes priority over what we would
call the real world
but to them tiktok is a much realer
world than anything they encounter in
three-dimensional space and they care
more about it that's why it's important
for us to know what's going on there i
would think also sites like tick tock
are kind of a far left staging ground
if you're plugged into that world you'll
have a jump on the new leftist ideas and
talking points before they make their
way into the mainstream
this is an extremely fast process you'll
hear some extravagantly pierced
blue-haired weirdo on tick-tock spouting
the latest insanity and a week later
it'll be an official democrat talking
point as the pipeline from leftist
extremism to leftist mainstream is not
very long at all but it can be helpful
to get the heads up anyway so for
example for example libs of tick tock
posted this yesterday it's a video from
non-binary activist and all-around creep
jeffrey marsh
giving what will soon become the
official answer to the what is a woman
question listen
here is madison hawthorne's definition
of a woman
x chromosomes no tally whacker
and this gives me a chance to talk about
biological essentialism
um first of all it's not true people
have all kinds of chromosomes and all
kinds of bodies women who've had
hysterectomies people born with certain
conditions but that's almost immaterial
number two
it is a system of oppression
gender is a hierarchy
and a system of oppression and the
easier it is to define gender the easier
it is to keep the oppression
going
it's dangerous
now uh by the way people do not have all
kinds of chromosomes women have xx
chromosomes men have xy chromosomes
that's the setup now the fact that a
very small number of people suffer from
genetic or abnormalities or deformities
which in those specific cases may make
the chromosomal situation somewhat more
muddled does not change the fact that in
principle men have xy chromosomes and
women have xx chromosomes there was a
case in 2006 of a chinese baby born with
a very rare birth defect that gave him
three arms
but this medical anomaly does not
invalidate the principle that human
beings have two arms
if somebody asked you how many arms do
human beings have it would be insane to
act like the question is unanswerable
just because the one kid in china had
three
okay but the real point for marsh is the
second thing he mentioned where uh you
know and i think we're gonna start
hearing this a lot more and he says the
question itself is oppressive even
dangerous
because gender is a system of oppression
the thing about that is you know if
gender is a system of oppression
then why aren't we getting rid of it and
just going back to talking about sex
male and female
why isn't he advocating that we see
ourselves simply as male and female and
within those categories people can dress
however they want and be as feminine or
masculine as they want wouldn't that be
the way to break down the oppressive
gender system
leftist radicals are the ones who
invented it anyway they came up with the
idea that gender is distinct from sex
why did they invent it if it's
oppressive
and why do men insist on being seen as
women and women as men if the whole
thing is oppressive
none of this makes any sense of course
but it's where leftist discourse is
headed and it's why these videos are
important
of course libs of tick tock has done
more than post tick tock videos uh
online though they she also has
especially in recent months had a hand
in breaking major stories about the
grooming indoctrinating going on in our
school system and i suspect it's this
last thing
you know revealing what's happening in
the school system that especially put
her in the sights of the elites who've
grown tired of being exposed and
humiliated by some anonymous account on
twitter and that's why they've now made
sure that the account is no longer
anonymous this morning the washington
post ran a major headline story which
serves no other purpose than to dox the
woman behind the libs of tick tock
account
headline says
meet the woman behind libs of tick tock
secretly fueling the wright's outrage
machine a popular twit twitter account
has morphed into a social media
phenomenon spreading
anti-lgbtq plus sentiment and shaping
public discourse
now the article goes on to provide the
full name of the woman behind the
account the city where she lives
her employment history
with originally with a link to her
employer
and they took the link out
but originally it was there
and it attempts of course to also link
her to january 6th because why not
the post reporter acknowledges that the
owner of the account has taken a number
of steps to keep her identity private
she obviously wants to be private she
wants to be anonymous
but the washington post revealed it
anyway
and this is where it's important to
mention that the reporter who wrote this
article is none other than taylor lorenz
now you may remember her from a few
weeks ago
when she was crying on msnbc
about being harassed and doxed let's go
back and relive that moment again
i've had to remove every single social
tie i had severe ptsd from this i i
contemplated suicide it got really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard
yes it's very bad when information gets
out that may be used against you
said the journalist literally a week
before she wrote an article doxing an
anonymous twitter account
this is exactly why you can't take the
tears seriously from these people
i doubt that these goblins are even
capable of experiencing real human
emotion anymore anyway
but if they are i hope that the backlash
lorenz gets for her libs of tiktok
expose is severe
i hope it makes her cry herself to sleep
every night for the next year
i hope it ruins her life some more
because that's justice it's what she
deserves
the only good news for her is that the
worst people on the internet aren't
going to come after her because she and
her friends are the worst people
so the worst thing that can happen to
her is that the second worst people go
after
maybe that'll be some consolation i
don't know
but we know why lorenz wants to make a
victim of herself she believes that her
tears give her license that they are her
credentials basically
which are supposed to confer upon her
moral superiority they're supposed to
make her untouchable and above criticism
after all what sort of monster would
criticize a woman with ptsd
well i will
her trauma doesn't mean anything to me
because it's not real
she deserves it anyway
the more interesting question then is
why they are going after libs of tick
tock in the first place
all the account does is simply repost
content
and it's not like she's digging through
dumpsters to find the content
okay and she's not doing what taylor
lorenz had to do
to find the um the person behind the
living tick tock account had to actually
do some digging to find it
she's not doing that
lives of tick tock she's going to one of
the one of the biggest social media
platforms in the world and she's just
reposting it
she's taking content that other people
put on this social media platform
because they wanted people to see it
and she's amplifying it
you know people on the left do that with
me all the time they take my videos and
things that i've said
and
you know things i've said on the show
and they they
reap media matters does it all the time
i don't have a problem with that
i mean i i want people to hear what i'm
saying
and that's all that lives a tick tock is
doing so why target her well that
question is also very easy to answer
as the saying goes sunlight is the best
disinfectant and she is helping to shine
a light into some pretty dark spaces
spaces that taylor lorenz and the
washington post would prefer to keep out
of the mainstream view
they will in fact do anything to keep it
out of you
as lorenz has clearly demonstrated
and that's why she is today finally
canceled if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends